supongamos que tenemos dos emprendedores
y que ambos están bien interesados en
adquirir una taquería y después vender
acciones de esa taquería entonces vamos
a compararlos déjame dibujar una línea
para dividir entre el primer y segundo
emprendedor entonces voy a poner una
línea así y van a comprar activo
idéntico van a comprar la taquería con
la plancha con la misma cantidad de
efectivo en la caja registradora todo lo
que se necesita para operar una taquería
también va a estar en 12 en ubicaciones
muy similares una junto a otra o bien
una enfrente de la otra en fin es
exactamente el mismo activo déjame
dibujarlo no creo que no quiero dibujar
una caja más bien un rectángulo entonces
este de aquí es el activo y costó 100
mil pesos eso incluye el edificio
incluye el tronco para pastor incluye
pues las mesas y las sillas e incluye
pues el uniforme para el taquero todo lo
que se necesita para operar el negocio
necesitas también un poco de efectivo
verdad para pagarle a los distribuidores
y comprar piñas para los tacos de pastor
y un poquito para poner en la cuenta
bancaria cosas de ese estilo entonces
todo esto incluye eso todo el activo
es todo lo que se necesita para empezar
la taquería entonces estoy acá es el
activo ambos compran activo idénticos
déjame copiarlo y pegarlo
ahí está
y listo compraron activo idéntico ahora
el primer emprendedor es muy conservador
y ha estado ahorrando toda su vida para
hacer esto entonces de hecho tiene 100
mil pesos para comprar toda la taquería
entonces se la compra así en efectivo y
así de repente ya es toda suya de modo
que todos los 100 mil pesos en activo es
su capital déjame poner capital en otro
color
entonces todo lo de acá es capital
aunque todo esto es capital
estoy acá pues a lo mejor es un poco más
joven o no es tan bueno ahorrando dinero
de modo que pues no tiene cien mil pesos
para pagar la taquería no sé digamos que
nada más tiene diez mil pesos para
empezar la pero sabes que sabe hablar
muy bien es un muy buen negociador y
entonces va al banco de la esquina y
dice tengo esta súper idea déjame le
pongo por aquí diez mil pesos eso es lo
que tiene entonces le dice al cuate del
banco tengo una súper idea agarra le
invita a sus tacos de pastor con su
cebolla su cilantro y su piña le
pregunta que si salsa verde o salsa roja
lo deja impresionado y no sólo logra
conseguir 90 mil pesos sino que logra
que a nombre de la taquería le presten
un poco más digamos 100 mil entonces
consigue 100 mil pesos y no sólo eso
sino también una buena tasa de interés
entonces consigue 100 mil pesos dejada
lo pongo por aquí
entonces obtienen un préstamo de 100 mil
pesos
y ahora tiene una deuda de 100 mil pesos
verdad hasta ahí más o menos 100 mil
pesos una deuda de 100 mil pesos
muy bien entonces ya tiene 110.000 pesos
para jugar verdad con esos 110 mil va a
comprar una taquería de 100 mil pesos y
luego tiene otros 10 mil pesos pues no
sé para hacer algunas apuestas
financieras digamos claro los tiene que
meter a la cuenta bancaria de la
taquería para que el banco vea los que
se usan para lo que se pidió pero su
intención real pues es más bien digamos
apostar en la bolsa de valores a nombre
de la taquería o no sé tal vez comprar
algunos instrumentos financieros de eso
peso o de garnachas pero para nuestros
fines vamos a pensar que es efectivo
déjame ponerle aquí que es efectivo ok
entonces ambos empiezan su taquería
hacen una gran inauguración y vamos a
ver qué sucede vamos a ver qué sucede
digamos en el transcurso de de un año
muy bien entonces vamos a poner por acá
ingresos por ventas
voy a ponerle aquí ingresos por ventas
entonces supongamos que en el primer año
es idéntico ambos ganaron cien mil pesos
por venta a 100 mil pesos 100 mil pesos
vamos a ponerle aquí el costo por bienes
vendidos es aproximadamente el 50 por
ciento digamos que son 50 mil pesos voy
a poner un menos porque es un gasto
menos 50 mil entonces su utilidad bruta
de ambos sería de 50 mil pesos acá
también 50 mil pesos
hay otros gastos verdad ventas general y
administrativo y bueno si viste el vídeo
de depreciación y amortización pues
puede que también incluya un poquito de
la depreciación de la plancha o tal vez
la amortización del patente de que se
llamen la taquería súper chida a lo
mejor ambos compraron este la misma
marca entonces digamos que son otros 20
mil pesos menos 20 mil por acá y menos
20 mil por acá hasta ahorita se ven muy
similares verdad bueno se ven idénticos
y esto es porque tienen exactamente el
mismo activo vamos a ponerle aquí cuánto
es utilidad operativa la utilidad
operativa 50 menos 20 30 30 mil pesos y
acá también 30 mil pesos pero aquí las
cosas van a empezar a verse un poco
distintas y esto pues tiene que ver con
lo que vimos en el primer vídeo verdad
como en ambos casos el activo se está
administrando pues de manera idéntica
entonces va a generar la misma utilidad
operativa pero aquella vez cuando
hablamos del activo únicamente teníamos
activo operativo acá el de la derecha
tiene un poco de activo no operativo no
necesita este efectivo para operar este
es efectivo más allá de lo que se
necesita
administradora digo a lo mejor aquí
tenemos un poco de efectivo verdad que
se necesita que esté en la caja
registradora o bien que se necesita para
pagarle al distribuidor de trompos de
pastor en cambio este de acá es efectivo
más allá del negocio se puede gastar en
cosas que no tengan nada que ver con
tacos por ejemplo invertir en la bolsa y
ahora tenemos un nuevo renglón que se
llama utilidad no operativa utilidad no
operativa este de acá no gana nada él no
está apostando y estoy acá digamos que
es muy bueno con sus diez mil pesos y
que por sus especulaciones tiene un
retorno del 20 por ciento o sea dos mil
pesos dos mil por sus apuestas en la
bolsa vamos con el interés este de acá
no tiene nada de deuda es muy prudente
no tiene que pagar nada de interés de
modo que su ingreso antes de impuestos
su ingreso antes de impuestos pues
también es de 30 mil pesos este de acá
si tiene que pagar interés y no sé
supongamos que de esos 100 mil pesos de
deuda consiguió una muy buena tasa
digamos que el banco central se dio
cuenta que era súper importante para el
futuro del sistema financiero y entonces
le dio una tasa de 2%
tenía miedo de que si está taquería
fallaba entonces todo el sistema
financiero se iba a colapsar ok entonces
le dan una tasa de 2% y 2 % de 100 mil
pesos que es cuánto 2000 pesos entonces
sería menos donde no sabes qué voy a
hacer un poco más realista
digamos que 5% y 5% resulta que no era
tan indispensable para el sistema
financiero 5% ok entonces ahora si 5% de
100 mil pesos de 5 mil pesos entonces
cada año tiene que pagar 5 mil pesos de
interés eso de ahí es su gasto por
intereses 3 interés éste su utilidad no
operativa este ya que su utilidad
operativa simplemente sigue de acá
verdad aquí sigue la línea entonces su
ingreso antes de impuestos ahora es
cuánto es 30 más 2 menos 5 27 27 mil
pesos lo que sigue ahora es que ambos
paguen 30 por ciento de impuesto sobre
la renta impuestos entonces éste está
pagando 10 mil pesos
ah no perdón verdad es 3 por 3 99 mil
pesos verdad acá es 27 por 33 por 27 81
con el punto recorrido
ocho mil cien pesos a ver ocho mil cien
pesos
sí sí está bien sí verdad acá es al
menos nueve mil ya cada tres por 7 21 23
por los 6 y 8.1 osea 8 mil 100 pesos
vamos al siguiente renglón al ingreso
neto ingreso neto este de acá es 21.000
pesos verdad y acá es quien está difícil
la resta bueno lo hago creo que es
18.900 si 18 mil 900 pesos
ahí está el ingreso neto y por supuesto
la diferencia es que este cuate de acá
tuvo que pagar un cierto gasto por
interés porque tenía un préstamo del
banco y si hacemos todas las cuentas de
la ingeniería financiera que hizo aquí
si quitamos los dos mil pesos que obtuvo
por hacer algunas cuantas apuestas en la
bolsa entonces si consideramos eso paga
tres mil de interés y con eso logra una
deducción de impuestos de creo que 900
pesos si o se ahorra un 30 por ciento de
tres mil pesos entonces son 900 pesos
pero bueno regresemos a lo que estábamos
habitando me quiero enfocar en los
ahorros de impuestos por intereses más
bien lo que quiero hacer es enfocarme en
ciertos
de evaluación lo que quiero ver
específicamente si el precio por
ganancia funciona en esta situación en
la cual el activo es idéntico pero
tenemos estructuras de capital muy
distintas para esto vamos a ponerle que
ambos tienen 10.000 acciones acciones
cambiaría de color arbitrariamente
10.000 acá también 10.000
entonces gp a este de acá es veintiún
mil pesos dividido entre diez mil
acciones
gpa es 2 pesos con 10 centavos y acá es
algo similar es 18.9 dividido entre 10
es un peso con 89 centavos por acción
ok y ahora pues no sé o sea podríamos
haber modelado un poco más sus estados
de resultados verdad que ambos tienen el
mismo ingreso por ventas y la misma
utilidad operativa pero como el de la
derecha tiene apalancamiento va a crecer
un poco más después voy a hablar un poco
más de cómo funcione sobre el
apalancamiento pero supongamos que
alguien ve esto y dice bueno es el mismo
negocio la misma industria el de la
derecha está creciendo un poco más por
su apalancamiento pero bueno sabes que
vamos a hacer este pues más o menos
moderados y ambos les vamos a poner un
precio por ganancias de 10 son estables
y todo entonces ambos merecen un
coeficiente de 10 esto quería decir que
acá están dispuestos a pagar 20 pesos
por acción y acá 18 pesos con 90
centavos por acción
muy bien pero ahora qué sucede con la
evaluación de la empresa lo que sucede
en términos de la capitalización del
mercado o sea la capitalización de
mercado aquí es 21 por 10 mil 21 por 10
es 210 entonces estamos diciendo que el
valor del capital de esta taquería es de
210 mil pesos no pongo aquí 210 mil
pesos de este lado estamos diciendo pues
otras veces 18.9 por 10.000 entonces es
189 mil pesos ok
ahí están las cuentas que les queda vale
un poco más porque ganó un poco más pero
el de la derecha diego ahorita está así
por simplicidad pero podría merecer un p
más alto de cualquier forma aquí está
pasando algo interesante aplicando el
mismo coeficiente de precio por
ganancias estamos diciendo que el valor
en mercado de este capital es de 210 mil
pesos verdad y el valor en mercado de
este capital desde que 189 mil pesos
ciento 189 mil pesos si era eso
si 189 mil pesos ok entonces aquí parece
que hay algo que no tiene sentido este
cuate puso 100 mil pesos se invirtieron
y tuvo un negocio muy bueno con mucha
utilidad entonces el mercado dijo un
gesto un negocio con mucha utilidad más
que la mayoría un buen margen de
utilidad después voy a hablar más de eso
entonces estamos dispuestos a decir que
el valor del mercado de tu capital es de
210 mil pesos que implícitamente está
diciendo que el valor en el mercado de
este activo también es de 210 mil pesos
verdad sí pues como dicen que esto vale
210 mil pesos y no hay deuda entonces el
capital también vale eso pero a la
derecha al darle el mismo coeficiente de
precio por ganancias el mismo
coeficiente pp y a lo mejor al de la
derecha ya que darle un poquito más por
su apalancamiento pero bueno al darle el
mismo precio por ganancias
tenemos 189 mil de este capital de su
valor en mercado pero sólo puso diez mil
pesos y de repente vale 189 mil y ahora
si esto vale 189 mil si este pequeño
cachito es 189 mil pesos entonces qué
nos dice acerca del activo pues vamos a
hacer las cuentas que quiere decir en
términos del valor del activo
pues tenemos 189 mil por este capital
esta deuda es de 100 mil pesos entonces
el mercado está diciendo que el lado
derecho de la hoja de balance es cuánto
de 189 más bien sería 289 mil pesos
doscientos ochenta y nueve mil pesos
supongamos que este efectivo sigue
siendo efectivo vale diez mil pesos
entonces si lo restamos el mercado está
diciendo que esté activo que es 289.000
menos diez mil o sea 279 mil pesos que
vale 279 mil pesos entonces hay algo muy
raro pasando aquí el mercado simplemente
por cómo está capitalizada está taquería
y el mercado pues le aplicó un precio
por ganancias de 10 ambas compañías y
está diciendo que esté activo vale 279
mil y que éste vale sólo 210 mil pesos
pero es exactamente el mismo activo así
empezamos el vídeo creo que ahorita ya
me gasté mucho tiempo en este vídeo así
que te voy a dejar pensando tantito y en
el siguiente vídeo te voy a contar que
la razón por la cual empiezan a pasar
cosas feas es que pues al coeficiente
que le pasan cosas feas cuando quieres
comparar dos compañías con estructuras
de capital distintas también
el siguiente vídeo te voy a contar otras
formas de medir empresas con diferentes
estructuras de capital que consisten
básicamente en quitarles el
apalancamiento pero bueno acá cuando nos
fijamos nada más en el valor de mercado
aquí parece que son negocios similares
este vale un poco más porque éste tiene
deuda pero bueno cuando regresamos al
valor implícito del activo de repente te
das cuenta que estás pagando de más por
este de acá bueno piénsalo tantito
piensa dónde está el enigma que está mal
dónde está el problema y en el siguiente
vídeo te daré herramientas para
resolverlo nos vemos